so it's budget day two the post-mortem
where think tanks get a sense of just
what these figures are do they add up
who's benefiting who's losing out the
most and on that front let's have a look
in particular at child care those Child
Care reforms more free child care for
many families how to who benefits here
this is called a distributional analysis
so you're getting a sense from the
porous through to the richest who
benefits the most the higher the bars
are the better off they're doing and you
can see it's mostly better off people
who do better out of that free child
care let's bring on Universal Credit so
that's the changes in Universal Credit
when it comes to child care but most of
all I'm going to bring on pensions look
at this the abolition of the lifetime
allowance the increase in the annual
allowance just look at who benefits the
most from that it is the wealthiest the
wealthiest by far doing best when it
comes to these measures but that's not
everything we need to take account of
the fact that taxes are going up as well
and in particular a lot of people are
being drawn into higher rates of tax
it's called the annual allowance it's
called fiscal drag basically when those
rates are frozen more people end up
paying them and were they kept in line
with inflation so raised in line with
inflation this is the higher rate tax
here the higher this is the more people
are paying it you can see that would go
down so people wouldn't be dragged in
quite so fast but because of fiscal drag
look at this red line it's actually due
to go to the highest level that we have
ever seen with 1.2 million people more
paying that higher rate of tax that's
fiscal drag when people talk about it
it's the fact that more people are
dragged into that higher rate of tax but
it's not just about tax it's also about
spending and what did we learn there
well we knew that there were plans to
increase spending pretty gradually in
the coming years but when you kind of
break down that one percent across the
whole of government here's a few things
we did know about so NHS spending going
up schools more or less flat defense
going up overseas aid up core child care
that was the thing we mostly learned
about in the budget that's up a lot but
what room does that leave for everything
else in fact look it's pretty depressing
the rest of the Departments around
Whitehall would potentially get a fall
in their annual allowance in in their
spending of three point 0.2 percent
that's quite a big four and raises some
questions about whether the chancellor
needs to do a bit more on spending but
that in turn raises another question can
he afford it and that comes back to how
he's doing against his fiscal rules this
is a measure of just how much Headroom
different chancellors in the past had
against their fiscal rules all the way
through from George Osborne through to
Philip Hammond the higher is the more
room they had so the safer they were how
did Jeremy Hunt to look that's really
low it wasn't a very safe budget in
terms of the fiscal rules despite that
it's worth saying markets seem quite
relaxed about it